Kathy what's the difference between a
low and a high concept movie and which
one favors new writers I think that the
low concept favors new writers only
because I think studios in general are
more willing to take a chance on
something that maybe is lower in in
budget but concept and budget are two
different things a high concept movie
usually means a higher concept budget in
general and that would be like your
action pictures your hero superhero
pictures things like Star Wars things
that have what they call the tent pole
you've probably heard that that term
before a tent pole effect it's just it's
a lot different I don't think it's you
and most of them you'll notice are based
on something that's been adapted from
another piece of of material like comics
a book novels that kind of thing but for
new people coming in new writers coming
in writing a nice refreshing project
that's in another arena that's not
doesn't require a huge budget and a lot
of special effects that's the way to
really get a sense of can they develop
characters can they carry a story all
the way through front for 90 minutes to
100 minutes and can they can they give
us good roles that actors want so that I
think is as better as if you try and do
a lower budget lower concept in terms of
genre or you know that's the way to do
it and just a reminder what's the
definition of high concept and low
concept again well high concept usually
means something that is you can you can
do a lot more with it in terms of well
they can always be sequels or prequels
those tend to be more high budget and
more high concept in terms of it's a
larger world more characters and they
can do like I said more with that they
can continue on an adventure with all of
those carrot
so that's why I think a lot of them
you'll see are adapted from other pieces
of material now what's a good test if
somebody thinks their script is
high-concept how can they kind of run it
through some tests because maybe they
find out it's actually low concept and
they're just not aware I think genre is
one way if you look at the ones that
usually make the most money or that are
based on other pieces of material a lot
of times they fall into science fiction
horror fantasy or siphon a see those are
the most popular genres for that
certainly if you look at things that are
action-adventure like The Bourne
Identity that's another one that you can
do a lot with because it's there's
always going to be a new adventure as
this guy is trying to find out his real
identity Kathy I believe you've told us
previously that you started out in the
studios and a typing pool and then you
started to be given notes and you
realized you were really in your element
so having having been in the industry
for some time how does the film and
television industry really work you've
seen it from sort of this level of being
a secretary in the typing pool sort of
being an observer maybe in hearing
things that people didn't even know you
were observing and then you from from
working your way up to a much higher
level how does it work well from that if
you want to do it as a basis of
comparison I think a lot of it has to do
with the technology first of all a lot
of things that were done on a typewriter
are no longer it's it's now on a
computer so technology is different I do
think that that there are more people
interested in becoming involved within
the studios and the network's I do see
that now there are one of the things
I've really noticed there used to be 10
to 12 studios and they're now something
like six six something like that
there's remember we used to have three
basic networks CBS ABC and NBC
and look how many cable stations and how
many smaller networks network for
television that we have we have
streaming we have more areas where a
person can get projects placed so that
is great because there's more
opportunities which I think everyone
needs you know so I think that that's a
good thing then that's also a huge
difference from what it was when I first
started off how does it really work
in terms of if you were to sit down and
have lunch with someone that's come from
another state or another country and
they have a vision of it
how would you sort of give them this
maybe fifteen minute briefing or less on
this is how it works it's it's either or
sort of an open system it's a closed
system led this is how the process works
of getting projects approved okay let's
take it just as you know just in sort of
very brief kind of terms if it were
about a script which I think you know
most I think most of your your fans
aren't interested in screenwriting in
terms of screenwriting it's different
now because you can give your scripts to
other people in terms of like Amazon it
has a little bit more open policy you
don't necessarily have to have an agent
I've heard of people who have just sent
things to Amazon and it's gotten read
there are more opportunities in terms of
there are all kinds of conferences now
where you can pitchfest
where you can make these contacts and
network they didn't have that 15 20
years ago there were you know there were
just very few opportunities to to be
able to have a writer meet with agents
and producers and executives now there's
more of those opportunities so
interesting so then but most people to
present their writing would need an
agent it would have to be through
somebody else well except for webseries
I mean which is another area that that I
think we'll get into a little in a
little while but webseries you can just
you could put that on Vimeo you can put
it on YouTube you don't really need to
have an agent in fact most people don't
have agents
that our that our web series creators
right so then in terms of getting an
agent
are there certain agents that aren't
able to pitch to studios on your behalf
or it's a free system in that way I'm
just trying to see from let's suppose a
total newbies perspective coming here
and thinking that they could just be
basically knock on the door and see the
you know the person at the front desk
and hand it over that's not really how
it works it's well you know to get an
agent you have to have material having
one scripts not going to do it know you
need to have at least I would say two or
three spec scripts and if you're get
breaking into television I would suggest
trying to get into some of the there's
fellowships and competitions for the
major CBS NBC and ABC they all have
screenwriting fellowship programs which
you can you know I'll give you a list of
them and you can if your readers or your
fans would like to you know take a look
at them I I have a list of them for them
and they have wonderful fellowship
programs where you can study with some
of their show runners and you can
they'll introduce you to some of the
show runners they'll have them come in
the show runners come in once a week and
talk with these people you know who are
there on the fellowship program and give
them hints and ideas about what they're
looking for how a television series
actually works how they how they put
things together with the casting and the
the plots and how do you continue a
story over a whole not just a season but
a series of of years you know they now
look for hopefully at least a five-year
season you know five-year commitment for
a television series so they learn all of
those things directly from these people
who are on the front lines so if you can
get into one of those fellowship
programs that's great and so I'll have
I'll have that fell all those websites
for the fellowship programs for you okay
does it give to your viewers
but in addition when it's when it comes
to age
it's still very hard to get an agent you
can get a manager you know how I told
you how things seem to be shrinking in
terms of like the the networks the
studios same thing with the major
agencies a lot of the agency started
merging about ten years ago and so they
don't have as many of the larger
agencies like they used to agencies now
have to be very they're very
cost-conscious and so a lot of the
agents when the agencies merged they
lost some of the some of the agents lost
their jobs so they became managers they
started using the term managers and they
also decided they wanted to produce so
there are a lot of managers out there
now so that's another area that you
might want to look into if you're a new
writer but I'd be careful about it
because it depends on one whether they
are looking just for the material or
whether they really want to be able to
help you out as a client some of them
are just looking just for the material
they may just want to do a quick buy of
it and have someone else rewrite it or
whatever you know so you you have to
kind of be careful about it because
managers are not they are not regulated
whereas agencies are regulated agencies
you can't charge you can't get more than
ten percent off of the sale of a
client's script or material and what
would be a way to see if someone was
actually a legit registered agent is
what website would help them uh you can
go to the writers guild and they will
tell you they have a list of the ones
who are legit and they will also tell
you the good thing too is if you do move
up with a manager or a producer a
production company if you start to think
that there might be something that's not
quite right call the writers guild and
they'll tell you if people have gotten
it complained about that I have had I
remember when I worked at Disney someone
called me and gave me their name and
they said I'm so and so I wrote
such-and-such script which was submitted
to you six months ago I have not heard
anything and I looked it up on my
computer and I
couldn't find it and I said well what's
your agents name and they told me and it
didn't sound familiar at all and so I
said you know can you do me a favor can
you tell me the name of your script and
I'll and your and your name and I said
I'll take all the information down and I
will check and see what's going on I
called the writers guild and they had
four outstanding complaints about this
person who was posing as an agent he
said in fact he said he was an agent
slash manager and he was not registered
with them so a lot of people pay money
to these people and you're not supposed
to pay money this this gal who submitted
her script he was asking for $25 for
each submission he would make to a
studio he said okay I submitted it to
four studios that'll be $100 so due
diligence can you even go on the website
yourself you know like the LA County Bar
or or the state oh you can just fine you
can do it that way too I mean it may
take a little bit longer because they
have to pry me they get emails all the
time where sometimes if you just make a
call you might catch the right person
they might be able to quickly look it up
in their database okay cuz I don't know
if they had their whole database on the
website I don't think they knew and for
something like complaints sure that
might be something better to talk to
somebody who's in person who is there
and can look it up for you and would you
recommend even if you have a good
feeling about somebody just to just make
sure that everything's it doesn't hurt
doesn't hurt okay the other thing too is
one of the best suggestions I can give
to new writers is join a writers group
that you can do it online now you don't
have to all just live in the same city
or anything you can do it online a lot
of people will trade via email or
whatever and just look at each other
scripts and give feedback and and be a
support system for one another but also
for some of the some of the people who
have actually submitted some material or
if somebody has actually gotten interest
from a production company they know
whether something works or not and it's
just like the same thing with screenplay
competitions there's so many of them out
there
and a lot of them all they do is they
just get the entry money and they really
don't give you any kind of value so what
I do every year is I I have several of
my clients that that I've that I do
business with and I always ask them I'll
send out a little questionnaire you know
what are some of the competitions that
you feel really work which are the ones
that you think are the best for new
writers to enter and you know I've put
out you know a little list of that now
I'll give that to you too
oh great and it really gives you a good
idea of the ones that are the most
reliable and it really is worth your
time and that's how another writer would
really know it's through word of mouth I
think word of mouth is the best thing
because if you know that some if there's
somebody that you know who actually has
gone through a competition or actually
has used an agent or even in things like
it like a consultant you know like gosh
I'm looking for somebody to you know
professional to read my script you know
who can you guys suggest who have you
guys used perfect way to do it you know
because word of mouth is everything to
me you know and that's how it works
actually in the industry when you talk
about agents you know that's how a lot
of people get agents is because they
know someone who knows the agent and it
goes by word of mouth that's one of the
best ways if you if you want to get an
agent but most of us don't know somebody
I mean I when I start on the business I
knew no one in the industry and so you
know I was not able to get a job that
way so the same thing for a lot of the
writers but I have I have clients who
eventually have gotten agents and it's
because they've gone to pitch fest or
because they they placed in a screenplay
competition so the form the the the best
thing is when you enter these
competitions make sure that they have
reputable people who are the final
judges mm-hmm are these people agents
studio execs Network people show runners
writers you know who are these people
that are doing the final judging
and if they have final judges who are
professionals in the industry they're
gonna be looking for clients they're
gonna be looking for material and it's
not unusual sometimes
whoever wins whoever wins the screenplay
competition it may not necessarily mean
that it that that project will get made
but there's always a possibility that
maybe they will ask him what else do you
have or she have you thought about
turning your script in instead of a
movie how about into a TV series
I've had a couple of clients who
actually have gotten agents just because
they placed they place like fourth or
fifth but they were but there are agents
who read the material and saw that there
is something about that material and
that writer that had a voice a different
kind of voice that they hadn't seen so
going back to the judges maybe just just
a quick google search of is this judge
working currently in the industry mm-hmm
and that's a good test the other thing
too is sometimes they don't know until
later on whether or not who's gonna
exactly be judging who the exact people
are so what you can always do is the
send it a little email to them and just
say can you tell me who is some of the
judges you've had in the past it gives
you an idea of the caliber of judges
going back to how does the film and
television industry work so let's
suppose someone has a reputable agent
they've checked them out and they know
that they're in good standing there's no
grievances or complaints and then
they've said this agent submit on behalf
of them to a studio what's the process
like what should they expect what's the
timeframe
what if it's optioned what what happens
that's a lot of questions at one time
certainly it does take time there are
more than a thousand pieces of material
submitted every month to the studios you
know maybe slightly less to larger
production companies but it's a lot of
material
somebody's got to read it it has to go
up a chain of command so it does take a
little while I would say reasonable time
they usually get things done you know
read
and we'll be able to tell you four to
six weeks roughly that's what it used to
be when I was working at the studios it
could be maybe slightly longer now
although a lot of a lot of times it's
now everything is now on the computer so
you could just read it at your at your
leisure you don't have to wait for
things to be mailed and that kind of
stuff
but I I do think that a lot of times it
also depends on who else is submitting
material there may be a more important
agent or there may be an agent who has a
script that has some famous actor or
director attached to it they are going
to get preference
so sometimes scripts get put that push
down a little lower a little lower a
little lower so you do have to watch out
for that and I do think that it's
important that people understand that
for first-timers it's you're going to be
there up towards the bottom and so it
probably would be longer so I would say
you know for just say four to six weeks
and if you don't hear anything what you
do is you just email or call your your
your agent and just you don't ask them
about it also find out from them if
they've heard anything because usually
they don't just submit it to one place
they usually try to submit it to a few
places because they want to get a
consensus of what of what in general
what the producers and the studio people
are looking for well let's suppose
somebody says we like it it's a go what
happens what are some of the
possibilities well first of all I don't
think they're gonna say it right away
but they will probably say we are
interested in this can you tell us more
and one of the other questions they're
going to ask what else do you have
because they want to know is just this
person if they like you're right in the
corner now what else do they have
and what genre is it is this somebody
that a writer that we want to kind of
like maybe get a jump on their other
material they're always thinking ahead
because they don't want to just put all
their eggs in one basket they want to
know that there's somebody that's got
free-flowing talent that's going to
continue to build a relationship on and
that's why agents are
is gonna ask that of you before they
take you on as a client what else do you
have what else do you have and that
because the studio and the producers
always ask whatever what else does this
guy have you know they want to know is
this does this writer have more material
because they would like to look at more
material Kathy what are some fatal
errors that a writer should avoid at all
costs Wow I I think one of the things
that you you need to know that it's not
just one script you have to think about
your whole career that you don't just
bank all your hopes on this one piece of
material you have to be working
constantly and that things don't happen
just like that one of the things I did
I'm in my book is I took a survey
I asked all of these writers who came
into the studios and that I worked with
I asked them you know a couple of
questions and one of them was how long
did it take you how many scripts that
you have to write before you either
before something major happened like you
got an agent or that you got an option
or somebody bought something I
interviewed over 200 professional
writers these are not waiter writers
these are professional writers only one
got her script sold the first script Wow
and she said it took five years for her
to get a second sale yeah
and the average actually turned out to
be eight or nine eight or nine scripts
of scripts okay Wow so it's it's if you
have to love what you do you don't want
to be a one script lender it doesn't
happen very often where somebody only
writes one script and that's it and then
nothing
they have to be writing constantly and
that's what agents and you know and
executives are looking for and producers
are looking for they want to build a
relationship you'll notice that people
like Spielberg and all the all the big
directors you
they'll all have the same credits the
same same people for you know
cinematographer script supervisor you
know and they go to some of the same
writers because they have built a
relationship with them because they like
their kind of storytelling because their
characters speak the same language that
they would like to convey to you know
movie viewers and so being able to have
those kind of relationships it's not
just writing it's also writing the kinds
of things that are going to continue
that relationship so I love the fact
that that most of the writers nowadays
have a better understanding of that and
they when I when I see the mat like
script fest or great American pitch fest
when I asked them I always ask them you
know what else are you working on just
to test them nowadays most of them will
say that they have more than one that
they're working on so I guess it's
working I guess they are getting the
getting that news that you need to have
more than one piece of material and a
lot of them are branching out in John
rus' whereas a lot of them first with it
oh I only like to do action-adventure I
only like to do romantic comedy and
nowadays I hear them branching out more
I'm wanting to do right I thought I you
know I thought I'd you know challenge
myself so I thought I'd do something a
little different so I'm doing a mystery
right yeah and it's it's nice to hear
that now that they're doing that and I
do think that I think it makes it for a
lot of the agents it's not just looking
at material and saying what's where's
that big tent pole thing it's also what
does this particular writer have do they
have that that it's best word to use do
they have that sense of adventure of
wanting to go further with their talents
as a writer to go further and and look
at other pieces of material and write
about something that is totally
different than what's out there that's
interesting how do you think they can
tell that someone has that sense of
adventure I think just by talking to
them and reading and what are you
working on you know what is it because
they want to know what it is that you're
working on oh yeah if I'm sure if they
give a one-line answer like
oh I'm working on another
action-adventure or I'm well you know I
like comedy so I thought I'd do another
comedy I say if you're only working on
what one genre or one thing that they're
that they that youth that maybe you you
did well on your first script and you're
only working on that yeah they're glad
to hear that but they want to know that
there's more what else are you giving
them that's going to be so different cuz
think they have to sell it they have to
sell it the agents have to sell it to
the producers or the petitioners have to
sell it to the distributors or the
studios so an openness and a willingness
if they see that you're too closed off
then maybe they realize it's a pass just
because down the wrong down the line
it's just not going to work okay yeah so
other fatal errors our writer make
either even in and just how they present
themselves or oh that's a good one I
feel that a lot of writers don't put
enough they don't invest enough in
themselves in terms of getting out there
and networking most common excuses are I
don't live in Hollywood or I don't know
somebody in the business or you know
they they you know they don't make that
investment nowadays social media you can
be just as up-to-date as anybody else
who lives in the city because you all
you have to do is just be able to go on
online develop a group like I said
there's writers groups that are online
and go to conferences invest in yourself
and that's I think that's one of the one
of the best pieces of advice I can give
to people consider investing in yourself
if this is something you want to do if
you're serious about it
you go to a college you go to college if
you want to be an engineer or a doctor
then you have to invest in yourself if
you're going to be a writer go to the
writing conferences or or they now have
a lot of them online do courses online
invest in in getting together with other
like-minded writers and going to writer
retreats or do just going out and
looking at all the material that's out
there
taking courses to you know to really
further not just your writing but to
further your network I don't like using
the term network so much I like to say
building a community of contacts and
when you do that it really makes a
difference because that's where a lot of
the connections start getting made you
know like there are people who were I
have clients where one of them you know
got an agent and there was another she
heard that her boss or her agent
that their agency was looking for
somebody who had an action-adventure
piece she remembered that the gal in her
class and her group had one and so she
got a synopsis and sent it to them now
they didn't buy it but they read the
synopsis and they said hey if you if you
you know if you have something else you
know feel free to send it to us they
didn't sign her but they expressed an
interest at looking at her work so just
that was just built built by the fact
that she was in the same writers group
is this woman so that's that is one way
you can you you can do that I also
suggest that if if people are really
serious about their writing invest in
going to a consultant and really getting
your material read by a professional and
there's so many people that specialize
and that's what's great because if you
have something that you know what you
should just be consultant and maybe it
was just for film but look for somebody
who maybe has a specialty in television
or you know whatever your project is and
look for someone that has those
interests or who has developed material
along that line there are certain
parameters I think that that I know that
as a consultant I don't feel I can do
everything so sometimes there's what if
i if somebody contacts me and they say
oh I've got this horror picture and I'm
not a you know I don't really I haven't
done as many in the horror genre and if
I don't feel I can give them exactly
what they want I'm very good about
recommending some of my other
consultants
friends who you know maybe would be
better a better fit but you know finding
that right person that you can consult
with and help help you really
restructure your work well that's
important and not too you know I
remember that that not long ago a lot of
people said well yeah but you know I
have my writers group or or you know I
have a cousin that that was an English
major whatever it is and yes though
people like that are helpful but you
want to get it from people who have
either worked in the studios or have
been in worked in production or have
been with a producer worked in
television whatever the whatever area
that you're looking at you know what is
the what have they done and it's
important to do your due diligence it's
just part of investing in yourself and
taking the time to research that and I
think a lot of writers don't because
they're so eager they just say oh okay
and they just Google consultants and
35,000 names here to come out you know
it's your due diligence to go through
and check them all out and to go you
know and check out with other writers
and find out go online and say hey you
know I've got a script it's a sci-fi
anybody else have a sci-fi and who did
you get as a consultant and once you get
a few names run them through the wringer
and then Google and see who you get and
who comes out on top
it's word of mouth is so important I do
think that you sometimes people are
really good at pitching and then they
don't have the material to back them up
and then we have conversely right we
have writers who have great material but
they have not spent enough time learning
how to pitch that's a huge mistake I you
know you can do pitching things online
you can do you can also go go - like
script fest there's a lot of other you
know organizations that have I think
there's virtual pitch fest - but there's
and I'll give you listings for that one
also but you can go to these these
different areas and say hey you know I
want to learn more and sit in on the
panels and the discussions and do some
of the practice pitches
and that's a lot of fun to do actually
it's somewhat and I do a course in fact
I'm doing one for the big break people
where I'm gonna have them pitch their
projects to me and I'm going to pretend
that you don't be the studio exactly and
it's it's gonna be a lot of fun I I look
at it as a good rehearsal for them
because during the the event itself the
awards event they're gonna be sitting
next to agents and producers and some of
the people that could make or break
their career you said something really
interesting and I think I've brought
this up in Prior interviews but I read
an article about how extroverts and
sometimes narcissists do much better in
job interviews versus introverts and
people that would actually be more well
qualified for the job but they don't
come across well when they present
themselves so I'm imagining that's the
same with pitches because I think a lot
of people and this is probably why
there's such great writers is they're so
internal they're so like worried about
things and thinking that they don't make
the best impression but they might
actually be the best person for the job
so it sounds like that's that's a common
thing with pitching that maybe people
that are great show people mm-hmm that
that they maybe don't have the material
as much to back it up versus the ones
that maybe are a little more shy or I
hate to use the term mousy but you know
somebody that might be less of a show
person writers in general most of the
writers I've met are a little bit more
introverted they're they're used to
working by themselves that's writing is
a solitary thing unless you write with a
partner but you know it's it's kind of a
solitary thing and it's hard for them to
express everything verbally in fact I
think it's probably more terrifying for
them to be able to talk about themselves
than it is to talk about their scripts
as well and I think that's one of the
things I always have to tell writers is
if you don't feel comfortable on in who
you are what you should do is write your
own kind of little personal story or
outline of who you are as an example one
of my favorites is I used to do the
interviews for the Disney and internship
program and there was a guy there from
you
CLA and he he had the most interesting
story about himself and I said tell me a
little bit about yourself because that's
usually how a lot of us start off you
know we will ask people tell us a little
bit so that can kind of ease you into
before you're doing the pitch and he was
so funny and he just said well I grew up
as a military brat and I was born and
you know Germany and I spent you know
five years there and then I spent four
years in Thailand with my you know my
dad was transferred to Thailand and then
and then I I ended up in the Philippines
and and anyway he says Here I am now
UCLA and this is my my fifth year at
UCLA and it's the longest I've ever
spent anywhere and one time and he says
but you know my favorite thing is I can
translate anymore I can translate any
movie I can read subtitles and and he
named off all the languages that he had
learned I thought like god what an
interesting guy he he has such a
beautiful worldview and think what he
can bring to his stories about the
diverse cultures about looking at things
through a different lens than just an
American lens and I then had him you
know come in and he talked to the rest
of our group and he talked about the
same kind of thing and we all loved him
and that was what nailed it for us is
that he had that kind of sensibility
about himself he wasn't afraid to just
sort of talk about himself and but he
did it in a way that made it interesting
and made us realize this guy could get
must give us a different he probably has
the ability to give us a different voice
in his writing interesting there are
other there are other you know ideas
that that have come across where I think
people don't understand that you do have
to talk about yourself to a certain
extent and I think people feel
uncomfortable about I think that's what
I one of the things I try to do when
when when I'm doing my networking
classes I try to do icebreakers so that
people
get used to being asked about themselves
and about their projects because maybe
they're taught that well you don't you
shouldn't be talking about yourself just
be talking about your project it's a
combination we are not only looking for
a project we are looking for somebody we
want to be in business with and that's
what I'm trying to get across is that
it's a two-fold thing and so when you
build your network of contacts that is
exactly what you should be doing
you should be talking about your
projects to these people you know to
your group but also letting them know a
little bit more about who you are as a
person these things stick in our mind
one guy came in and he had actually
gotten a couple of jobs you know doing
small little rewrites and he had done
some punch up stuff for comedies and I
remember he kept looking at his watch oh
you're having a meeting he he was
pitching a story to me he kept looking
at his watch and I finally just said do
you need to go somewhere do an
appointment and he just said I really
feel embarrassed but I'm really into
fantasy baseball our fantasy baseball
league I'm supposed to meet some friends
and and it had been he did a movie he
did a conversation with me and it was
unfortunately at the end of the day and
I was running late and so he was kind of
concerned about that but it didn't work
out but he did give me a good pitch in
terms of you know I but what was funny
is that one thing his honesty about
saying well you don't write I'm sorry
I'm just a big nerd about this fantasy
baseball thing and I that's stuck in me
I it was so funny six months later the
head of studio said you know what my
kids doing little again I want to talk
to you no I think we should do something
about Little League do you know how
fanatical people are and about Little
League and about baseball and stuff like
this and and so anyway it's it was one
of those things where he says we need to
do a project on this and we need to find
a writer so maybe we can if we can talk
to a bunch of writers about this so
guess whose name came
immediately I thought oh let's get Kevin
and so we did this thing where we had
some other some of the other execs too
had people that they had in mind him to
come in and we listened to about five or
six pitches
Kevin's was like head and shoulders
above all the rest
because he was a fanatic about baseball
it was just that one little sentence
that he gave me where you're networking
with people and you're letting somebody
know a little bit about yourself and
opening up and so that's why I want to
encourage riders to do that I think it's
important that they open up about who
they are - I've been reading this book
called lol I think the writer is
Christie Deerling and it's about her
life growing up poor and then she became
this multimillion-dollar salesperson and
and the vice president of a company she
talked about what she learned that was
the poverty mentality versus people that
break out of that and that is a
willingness to find a solution that
people that stay in a poverty mentality
Wow don't and those who break out they
find solutions they have a problem they
find a solution
that being said people creating
opportunities for themselves in in LA as
a writer it doesn't even have to be LA
but those who don't and say I don't know
what to do can't find you know I've been
submitting whatever verses those who
find a way out of that problem what have
you noticed
well the it you know I think what you're
saying is true I do think you know week
let's let's face it we can't have it all
we can't we can't be perfect in every
single area and I think one of the one
of the things I've noticed you were
talking about late you know earlier we
were talking about the fact that there
are differences in how things are done
in the industry now and one of the
things is there are a lot more people
who are who are into career counseling
as consultants and sometimes when you
get stuck and especially with writers
because it's writers are so in usually
so internal about how they they process
things sometimes it's hard for them to
be
external and try and and get things out
there and to do it the right way I know
that there are several people that that
are now career counselors who have
really helped in that area to try and
bring they talk to you and find out what
it is about you that that they feel is
special and and what is it about your
writing that's meaningful and they try
to bring that out in you and for you to
use that to help you to you know with
your work and I do think that that's
something that that the writers can look
into not just writers but I know actors
and actresses too a lot of times they
have to go to career coaches to help
them out with that you would think
actors and actresses you would think
that they would be very external and
very out there but a lot of actors and
actresses I've met there's a lot of
self-doubt sometimes behind them and so
every once in a while they get get stuck
that's what they they sometimes do they
go to career coaches to help them out so
there are career coaches that they that
are specialists in terms of with writing
let's say somebody at this point can't
afford that what are some of the things
people can do to create an opportunity
for themselves it sounds like a writing
group or any type of writing group is
wonderful is good the more people you
communicate with who are doing the same
thing you are doing means more
opportunities because I've noticed that
if one person finds a little bit of
success they're willing to share it and
you know like if they get an agent or if
they if they get a producer to read
their material they're then ready to say
oh well you know maybe I can you know
help this person who has a project that
maybe that producer is looking for as I
mentioned earlier that that's what
happened was one of my clients when she
was in a writers group so I think that
that that really does help I do think it
also helps if you have if you go to
different you know in terms of
networking there are networking groups
that they have here in in LA there's one
that I think it's the first Friday of
each month
and I think it's called First Friday or
something and but they have a group
where people get together and they will
say okay we are meeting at such-and-such
usually it's a cocktail bar or something
you know some some group you know
restaurant or something and a lot of
times there's other writers there
there's also other writers who have made
it who were in that group who sometimes
come so there's there's things like that
somebody else I know said that when they
first moved here they knew no one what
they did is they went they went and
googled writer screenwriter meet up and
they came up with a list of things and
she went to every single one of those
she formed her own writers group from
the people that were of interest to her
that really she thought she made it a
connection with it she now has a lot of
a lot of friends she came here knowing
no one
she said North Dakota and she said there
was nobody in her town that you know she
she put up a little thing saying any
screen I should put it up the local
University at that you know in her inner
town and nobody there's nobody there
that that said anything about yeah
they're they're interested it's great so
she felt okay I guess I gotta move to
you know to California and so she just
took a leap of faith and she did that I
mean it doesn't work for everybody but
it sure worked for her and she now has
an agent she has been doing punch-ups
she she's really a great comedy writer
and so she's been doing punch ups and
she's been doing some stuff for
late-night they've tried her out doing
some stuff for a late-night comedy work
you know to do writing there so you know
it's it's kind of interesting to see how
people start to make slow progress just
by being you know by the connections
that they're making I think we all know
someone that has great intentions but
that maybe they just kind of wait for
emails they wait by the phone
and they don't do anything about it what
have you seen from that sort of type
that gets them out that that they stop
waiting and relying on someone else and
they and they start making opportunities
just like the woman that started her own
meetup group and I think that's an
excellent idea but that's kind of scary
I mean that takes a leap of yeah I get
it she knew some
people but I mean still it's
intimidating but what do you see well I
think the most she told me the most
intimidating thing was moving from North
Dakota up shorter that's that's scary in
itself it was scary but she figured if
she could do that she had nothing to
look she looked at it about when she
went to these meetup groups
she knew nobody she figured she had
nothing to lose and everything to gain
and I think a lot of it is your attitude
when you come in if you if you are
looking for something and you really
want it you make the effort to let
somebody get to know you better and and
it does it takes a huge leap of faith
but it's it's worthwhile in the long run
for most people who do put themselves
out there it's not easy but you know you
you have to do that I mean there are a
lot of people who just give up and if
they give up it meant to me it means
then it's then it wasn't meant for you
that that wasn't meant for you but if
you stick with it something eventually
is going to happen like I told you I
interviewed over 200 these people who
are professional writers the average was
8 scripts there was one guy who is now
on staff on television he's a really
good television writer and I asked him I
said well gosh how did you feel you know
what hey you know how many scripts it
took him
it took him 12 scripts Wow and I said
well what did you do you know like when
you woody just ate eight scripts or
something he says you know what I don't
know there just was something about I
could not stop I mean it became like I'm
gonna do this and he just had to do it
and he just kept writing and writing and
he finally got to that 12th script and I
and I saw I said to him I said she I'd
like to read some of those first ten
scripts and he goes no I don't think he
want to and I said well yeah but I'd
like to see what they were like and he
goes you know what I I don't let anybody
read them I said well do you still have
him because yeah I haven't been a drawer
in the bottom of my desk and I said well
why are you keeping him then and he said
it's to keep me humble because how could
I even think I look at those ten eyes
how could I even think that I was a
writer when
I read those 10 scripts I mean that's it
it just amazed me and this guy's quite
successful I mean he makes six figures a
year you know as a writer and he's doing
quite well but it took him that long and
so it does it you have to have that
determination you just have to do it you
know if you you can't just say well you
know well I guess it's not gonna happen
it's like you have to do I always tell
people it's like you're knocking on
Hollywood's door they aren't gonna
answer if you're you know you're not
gonna get that door open if you don't
answer you just give them the answers or
you don't tell them anything what it is
that you want and it's not just what you
want you have to show them what you have
so want and have or two different things
you know you can dream about it but you
have to make the dream come true
dreaming about it and not doing anything
about it all right that's that's the
difference between success and failure
and I some of the people that I've seen
that I've known for years who now are
doing quite well in the business it's
because they deserved it they really
stuck to it they just couldn't help
themselves they had to keep writing and
they believed enough to themselves that
they said you know I got to do this a
lot of times they had to take two or
three jobs in order to do it a lot of
times they family and marriage and
family came and you know and went in
between all of that because I asked one
of them on time his wife was a teacher
and they have twins and so he had to be
the one to stay home and take care of
the twins which is not easy and I asked
him how did you do it and get your
assignments in on time and he said he
basically had to stay up at night and do
it he would set the alarm he'd go to
sleep at 10 o'clock he would get up at 3
o'clock in the morning do the feeding
and then he would work for three hours
straight until he got and he gave
himself you know that he would have to
write so many words you know or Saurus
or how many scenes or whatever it is and
that's how he did it he just stuck to it
and he said there were times when he
would sit there and he would be waiting
and waiting for those words to come and
it wouldn't and he finally would just
start writing down random
words and pretty soon he would come
across something he said it would just
like oh wait a minute that word oh okay
and then pretty soon it would start to
flow and he says he doesn't understand
it to this day he just knows it happened
and he said he just that's what he he
did but he always made sure he said even
on those times when he felt like he
couldn't do it he just felt he had if he
wasn't going to write he was gonna sit
there and stare at that page and just
write random words until something came
to him because he felt he had to at
least physically be doing it or
physically typing it up for him to be
able to feel that okay even if I don't
come if I didn't I'm not sitting here
with an idea in mind I'm just gonna keep
typing something until something strikes
me and that's literally how he said he
got some of his assignments done he some
of them were some of it was trash you
know he didn't you know he would type
for an hour and nothing would come up
and then all of a sudden something would
click so I think he just felt that he
had to do it he forced himself to do it
and it worked for him and he had the
weirdest hours but it worked for him
should a writer aim for a certain amount
of rejections per year and if they're
not getting those rejections and that
means they're probably not getting out
there enough Santa interesting way to
look at it or maybe I'm too negative
here that's entirely possible
I you know I don't know if there is such
a thing as a certain number of
rejections you know whether you are
setting the bar for something you know
for failure or not I think you know
instead I would turn it around and say
okay I think once a week set a goal for
doing at least one piece of marketing or
two pieces of marketing I think that's a
better way of looking at it than saying
okay I've had 10 I've reached the
threshold of 10 rejections this month so
I'm not gonna do anything now I mean
that to me is more negative so I would I
would say okay let's do this in in a
week let's let's look
why don't I look up you know five
different places that I can send out
letters or that I can send emails to or
why don't I look up ten different
resources for competent screen
screenwriting competitions or something
doing something like that I think is
much more productive because you never
know when one of those are gonna come
but to just say well okay if I did this
many rejections then that means I it
because who knows if you didn't do that
next one to fine pieces of marketing
marketing just means making the effort
to get out there whether it's posting
something you know that that you feel is
you know like there are places that you
can post your your story ideas you know
and your your synopses and then if
someone's interested they will then
contact you and then you can let them
you know look at your script and they
can you can get your script read so you
can post your projects you can be you
can you know to me it's not just posting
a project it's also like making plans to
enter a competition making plans to send
out you know to go to a conference or
something those are positive things that
are moving in the direction and you have
to invest in yourself I understand that
sometimes people go yeah but it cost
money to enter a competition or yeah it
costs money to go to a conference well
you know if you if you if you're really
if you're really serious about it you
have to make the investment in yourself
somehow and so maybe you have to be a
little bit more frugal about things okay
maybe I can only spend ten dollars or
something or twenty dollars or whatever
it is a week that I'm going to do this
to sock that away for it but whatever it
is you make those plans I mean that's
that's just it I mean I know that I I
have clients who have done who did it
for years before something happened for
them but now things are working for them
or they really feel like they can't
and they're really doing some some
really good work and it takes a lot of
time you can't just expect it to happen
overnight it because it doesn't and that
that certainly that survey I took of all
those professional writers proves that
it doesn't work overnight it took that
one writer who did 12 speak 12 scripts
before he got an agent I think he said
he he wrote those 12 scripts over 15
years oh wow and you were sounds like
you were very surprised to hear that
numbers I was and you I was this is this
is a guy who was a top writer you know
yeah you would think that oh well you
know something must have happened and
right away something you know that that
it would continue and continue but and
also like the the one guy I told you
about who on her first script got
somebody to read it and buy it but it
took her five years and had four more
scripts before she got somebody to
option her second one and it never got
made unfortunately they optioned it at a
studio and then a new set of people came
in and you know and they didn't want to
continue with that particular script but
you never know I mean those that's how
how this business is you know I'm
hearing that a lot of regime change and
and how should someone stay current
because it is difficult when a new group
of people who don't know you and maybe
they had sort of a relationship with you
come in how do you ingratiate yourself
to a new regime well it's hard to
personally do that but to be aware of it
what you need to do is like and
especially if you have a writers group
if you guys together get a subscription
you know to the reporter or the brighter
whatever one you want you choose and you
guys share that share the subscription
and you know in fact there's there's
people who have writers group where
people take turns doing it so that once
a month they they rattle off ok here's
what here's what I read and you know and
here's and here's the latest news of
that that I've gotten and then that the
next person next month another person
doesn't so that everybody is well
but reports everything back to everyone
and I think that's a nice way of being
able to do it's networking but it's also
getting out really good solid
information hey so-and-so is no longer
at the head of this this production
company hired a new story editor this
but you know it's information that that
is valuable to the whole group and
that's that's how you keep current
naturally if you have an agent or
manager they should already know these
things but don't count and this is
another I think a mistake that a lot of
writers make they feel that if they have
an agent or a manager they don't need to
do anything right and one of my friends
one of my best friends actually has won
an Oscar and she tells me that a lot of
her a lot of things that happened it's
not because she has an agent or a
manager it's because she made the effort
to go out and talk to people and to find
out what was going on and you know she's
kept up her even though she lives out of
town she doesn't live in Los Angeles but
she keeps up with email and you know
phone calls and she is in touch with a
lot of the producers and production
people that she used to do business with
when she was living down here and she
said it's been the most valuable lesson
that she's learned is to keep those
contacts and send Christmas cards or to
give him a call every once in awhile and
you'd be surprised one of the things is
that she happened to write a movie for
somebody who was at a television star of
a television show I'm not gonna mention
the name of it or anything but that
actress her star really rose and what
happened is my friend happened to see
her at at a Writers Guild event and went
up to her and talked to her and the
woman looked at her and she goes oh my
god you're the one who wrote the script
for that movie is the week that helped
my career shoot up and it was like she
she remembered her name because of that
I think you know and so she says you
know
if you get a chance you know if you if
you're writing something you think I
might be good for it please let me take
a look at it and sure enough a year
later and my friend since that said it
to her and so they took a look at it
there I don't know if it's anything has
come of it yet but I do know that that
it's something that is on their mind so
it's on their radar and they might be
doing it there's some other material
that she's doing that other commitments
she has so you never know you know going
back to the idea of focusing on
solutions and not wallowing in well I
can't do this or whatever let's say
there is a regime change and you can
just tell that the relationship that was
once there the fit that the the culture
of that place has changed and maybe
you're not a fit anymore
how can someone find a solution and that
instead of wallowing in well they don't
want me and I'm gonna feel bad to keep
keep track of where that initial person
was where did he or she go because they
are gonna have an influence their
mindset their preferences and genres or
whatever are going to be going to
another production company or another
agency or another network or whatever
find out where that other person goes
interesting okay and you could send a
little thing up congratulations on your
new home at such-and-such you know I
really enjoyed working with you and I'm
sorry that that I'm sorry to hear that
you won't will no longer be at
such-and-such but I'm really happy that
you're at this new position position and
I think that helps it kind of keeps the
relationship going okay that's that's a
great way so the solution is then you
find the place where you were a fit and
the person that you did sort of work
well with and you just say hello see
that you've moved on congratulations on
the new job and instead of trying to
beat your head against a wall and say
they don't want me anymore gotta try not
to take your person okay right cuz like
I said there's always that there's a
thousand scripts that come to the
studios every month
those are scripts that call come from
agents and producers and entertainment
attorneys which is by the way is another
way you could that if you
on a higher an entertainment attorney
it's costly but a lot of people will
sometimes do that but in all aspects of
the business here it seems like groups
change their there's a lot of people
they move from one position to another
and that can really make or break how
easy it is for someone to continue a
relationship and the opportunities there
it just could be a simple thing as they
don't really know you
and they already have people in place
that they do know and so instead of
letting that stop you finding those
people and where they go it's I mean
it's so funny because the industry the
entertainment industry is mimicking
corporate corporate stuff that that we
grew up with I mean I you know I love
people there their parents work for the
same company their whole life you don't
do that it's the same thing people used
to work for studios that was all they
they only worked at one studio or maybe
two studios it's not like that anymore
and besides that it used to be like that
was kind of frowned on that the if you
were jumping around your job the job you
know and I remember my parents they were
kind of concerned well you're not at
Disney and now you're over at Island and
now you're over at Paramount what's
going upon you know how are you ever
gonna you know are you gonna find a home
you know I'm gonna find a company you
want to work with and I said it's not
that I don't want to but you know their
needs and my needs change and so
sometimes you know if you're not a good
fit you're not a good fit that's one
thing is is that one of it and that's
actually one of the reasons why I
decided to leave the corporate end of
things uh you know rather than to work
in the studio system because that's that
wasn't what I like to do my goal was not
to run a studio when I was doing it was
because I enjoyed working with writers
the further up the ladder you get the
less you're working with the writers you
you're then having to work with with
more with the agents and the producers
and then you know and I loved working
with the writers that was that that
really always has been my favorite thing
to do and the thing that I think where
my strengths shine through so becoming a
consultant was was a no-brainer for me
we've talked to John Truby and he said
to us when we interviewed him that
Hollywood doesn't really buy and sell
screenplays it buys and sells genres do
you agree to certain extent yeah I do
they are looking for material because
because they are corporation they are
looking for material that can be
transitioned to a lot of different
platforms
story they're looking for stories that
can that aren't just movies but they can
be games they can be plays they can be
musicals they can be a book they can be
a graphic novel and vice versa all of
those other things like there are a lot
of graphic novels my favorite story
about a graphic novel that became a
movie was one called snowpiercer which
was just amazing and I was worried that
they would not be able to capture it in
a movie but they did a very good job on
it but there are a lot of different
things you annual notice and most of the
superhero ones came from the comics so
transmedia sounds like okay well it's
not I mean it's not just transmedia I to
me it's it's like just it's it's
adaptation we usually think of
adaptation of only being from books to
film but adaptation means just taking
one piece of material a story or a piece
from that section from that and putting
it into another way of expressing it
it's just like I was at Disney when they
were doing Beauty and the Beast or
redoing Beauty he says you know as a
modern animated story with all the
wonderful songs and everything Jeffrey
Katzenberg loved that story
in a song so much that he had it come
here I mean he had it turned into a
musical here so we actually had it
before Broadway had it it became so
popular here that they eventually took
it to Broadway now they are turning it
into a live-action one
it's gonna be shown I think it's in
March next month it's now gonna be an
actual live action so it's sort of like
it's taking different routes but it's
being used it's the same basic story but
they're using it in different ways you
know and finding you know new audience
to look at it and and some of the fans
of the story are gonna come back anyway
and see it in the new form as a live
action instead of it just doesn't
animated movie potential pitfalls or
traps a screenwriter should be aware of
when trying to sell their screenplay
pitfalls hmm I think the biggest one is
don't try and make your project be one
of those where you're forcing trying to
force it into being what they think the
studio wants or what that production
company wants that's a big pitfall for
me because then somewhere along the line
I think you sometimes will lose the
heart of what your project is I know I
know a lot of times they they will ask
for a request to do something to it and
you you do need to if they bought it it
is their project and so I think a lot of
writers sometimes immediately are very
protective of their project and they
don't and they say well yeah I'll sell
it to you but you can't do this or you
know I mean that's sort of a first
reaction what they have to understand is
that they've got stockholders usually
that they have to answer to and and
there's when money is involved there are
some changes they have to make I think
when they when you are just in the
talking stages sometimes they make
writers make the biggest mistake is when
they start being too too concerned about
all of that and I want them to
understand it's good to listen first to
what they have to say before reacting
immediately and jumping all over it I
think you need to listen to what people
have to say and then talk it over with
your agent or talk it over with the
creative executives there which is the
kind of work
to do and a lot of times I had to
explain to him the reason why they asked
for a certain change maybe it was
because of budget a lot of times it's
because maybe they got a director and
the director maybe didn't like a certain
aspect of it or maybe it was an actress
or an actor and maybe their acting range
doesn't cover sufficiently the emotional
impact of a certain scene I mean there's
a lot of reasons that that people don't
understand about it so if you are
fortunate enough that somebody is
optioning or buying your project and
they are asking for things it's not
because they don't like it they want to
see it get made and sometimes it's
because of certain reasons and you need
to sit down and talk to somebody about
it don't just immediately get you know
all up in arms and just I know I'm not
gonna do that and I hate this I did you
know listen to what people have to say
sometimes it's something that says a
small enough thing and there's sometimes
there's this way she can compromise half
of my job when I was a creative exactly
was trying to find the best way to still
keep the project there as the writers
vision as well but sometimes if you have
a director who's a big name you have to
waive the consequences do we do you want
to keep the big are they going to keep
the big name director or or the
first-time writer and it's a real easy
thing for the studio it's if they figure
we've already bought it we don't need
the writer to come back and do the
rewrite and you want to stay in business
with people so you have to learn when to
to fight and when to listen to what's
being said and when to give in you know
and it doesn't mean you completely give
in talk to the you talk to the creative
because usually there's at least two
execs there's the the usually there's a
VP and usually there's a creative exec
talk to the creative can find out their
reasons why and see if there's some way
that there can be some kind of a
compromise to it and a lot of times that
was that like I said that's that was a
great deal of my the
that I did was working with the writers
and I think that's why I was as
successful as I was is that the writers
liked the fact that I would talk with
them and I wasn't afraid to say well
okay here are some that here are some
options we can do which of these options
do you think fits your story best if I
would give them options then they felt
they were more in control I wanted to
give that to them so they wouldn't feel
that everything was lost to them I think
sometimes executives have a way of being
very to-the-point and very Bruce Lee
okay we need to change this scene
doesn't work and sometimes they don't
explain why that's part of what a
creative exec does and so I think that
that's something that you know if you're
not sure if writers are not sure they
should talk to somebody and just say can
you explain that to me in a little more
detail because I wasn't quite sure what
it means that it doesn't work exactly
what is it about it that it didn't work
so I don't know if that I hope that that
helps because I do I do feel that there
have been a lot of writers who have lost
an opportunity to have their work
produced because they immediately jumped
up and they just said no I won't do it
because they were too precious with it
mm-hmm and they didn't even want to
listen to what you know the explanations
or anything
how many working Hollywood writers do
you know that don't live in Hollywood oh
gosh I think once once you do quite well
in terms of film you can work just about
anywhere I know several writers in
Hollywood that that don't work in
Hollywood they live somewhere else and
you know nowadays with technology you
can just you can you don't even have to
come down for meetings you can just do
it by the web and it works out quite
well so that's the good part about it
but in order to get established
sometimes it's a little harder for the
first-timers to be able to you know to
do that
but even then it's better than it used
to be because sometimes what they do is
if they likes it like as a for instance
one of my clients actually
was one of the finalists and in one of
the script competitions and they there
was an agent that was interested in his
work and so the agent set up a meeting
on the internet and now he's represented
I mean so it's you don't necessarily
always have to come here I mean it's not
you sometimes you might have to for
television television is one of those
things where you sometimes are on the
set making changes making Krista script
changes so if your goal is to work in
television sometimes I understand that
you you do need to sort of be here they
like staff writers here on the set
because they're always changing things
around and they also have to work for
especially in comedies they're working
with comedians and so when you change
something it's got to fit into that
person's how he delivers things what hit
what what is his style of comedy and so
it's got to be you got to be right there
with him so that he can you know when
he's you're making those changes he can
approve them or he can try them out I
know you've interviewed over 200 writers
for your book of that group or even
others that you've known through groups
what sort of against all odds'
screenwriter story has really stuck out
to you where it seemed like success was
never going to happen
you don't have to name the project or
really any identifying things about the
person but just something that it just
seemed like this person was never going
to cross over to a level of success that
they wanted and they did and it was
pretty amazing I think the example that
I gave you earlier about the guy that he
it wasn't into his 12th script that he
finally got an agent and even when he
got the agent it still took two more
years before he finally got something
option so you know it's it's a long
process but I I am so proud of him
because he stuck with it and I think you
know he he just I always ask him I asked
him about it I said you know I just
still don't can't believe that you that
you just stuck with it that long and he
says I don't know what it is he says but
after about nine or ten scripts I wasn't
gonna get let it get the best of me I
just felt I had to keep going and he did
it and it's just you know it's one of
those triumphs of the human spirit thing
you know it's like I'm I'm not gonna
damn I'm not gonna let this happened to
me I'm just gonna keep at it and he kept
doing it what really helped is that he
had a daughter that really believed in
him and she was a little girl when he
was starting to write all these scripts
and she was in college by the time that
you know he finally got a you know a
script sold and everything and she just
said there was something about my dad
she says he just wouldn't let up he just
kept doing it and she you know she's so
proud of him in-between there was a
divorce so which was not a good thing
and and I was worried about him at that
point I mean there was just something
really special though about him and I I
to this day though I you know I we still
exchange you know Christmas cards and
stuff like that but he just is a
wonderful individual and I am so you
know when I think about people trying to
make it nobody deserved it more than he
did he just stuck with it he would not
let it get get him down what are some
common mistakes that you see web series
creators make over and over again oh
gosh I think one of one of the things is
that a lot of people don't understand
exactly what a web series is and
sometimes that what they're trying to do
is they're trying to take maybe a script
that they a film script that's like $100
$189 vision set you just click the
remote and if you change channels and
you can click and go up go to another
web series very very easily if you don't
catch someone's attention right away
and people don't understand that you
can't just take a film script and chop
it up and that's it you have 90 minutes
or a hundred minutes to tell a whole
story you need to capture somebody's
attention right away within the first
two or three minutes so a lot of people
especially cuz I'm with a la webcast I'm
on there they're bored and one of our
common complaints when we get people
sending in things in is they will have
web series that are sometimes 15 20 25
minutes long that's not a web series
that's a short film and so we in fact a
lot of the web web fests people now
we're trying to limit it to keep it
because a web series is this it we like
to show them and we like to show as many
episodes as we can but we can't if
somebody's got 25 minute episodes then
it's taking up too much time so we tell
people a web series you know if it's
comedy it shouldn't be longer than about
6 minutes if it's a drama no more than 8
to 10 minutes at the most per episode so
I think it's understanding that web
series should be looked at as as its own
medium and not that oh this is a movie
and just cut up into little pieces
interesting and how many episodes would
you recommend most web series have you
know the average web series I've seen
some that were as little as maybe 4 or 5
episodes for one season I would say the
average is 8 to 10 a season you know and
dramas tend to be slightly longer as I
mentioned that most of them I would say
are between 8 to 10 minutes and the
comedies are usually more like 4 to 6
minutes some of them are as short as a
minute and a half two minutes what are
your thoughts of a web series creator
making a web series and aiming for
sponsorship right away I'm hearing that
from a lot of webster's we all we're
looking for spot and that's like the
only goal behind it well if you don't
have a if you don't have a product
you're not
to get a sponsor I mean it's like it's
the same thing as saying okay I gotta
find a studio to distribute my movie
well you haven't written the movie yet
so I think a lot of people get misled
into thinking well as long as I have
this crowdfunding campaign going and I
can get money raised then you know I can
I can do all of this
most of the webseries people that I've
talked to a lot of them they just start
off just because they felt they needed
to do it and they wanted to do it now
they and they had so much fun it was
just a bunch of people a lot of times
they they were cousins or brothers and
sisters siblings or some a lot of times
it was just kids in a dorm that just
decided let's let's do one you know and
they just did it and they would we've
had some that have been as primitive as
just using your iPhone and we had some
that have been very sophisticated where
you know they actually is wonderful you
know technical things with camera and
stuff like that and some have one you
know brilliant you know special effects
and all that it just depends on where
you're at and what your story is some of
the more successful stories though I
think are the ones that are done just
because these people felt they needed to
be done and they just they and they had
an interesting set of characters in an
unusual circumstance as an example you
know some of this I love the stories
that come behind the webseries and and
one of the things that I've that I've
been doing is I've been asked to go to
the different web fests around the world
talking about web series that concern
social issues and it was very
interesting is that one of them is
called fafsa teen and it was about there
basically it was called faceting because
it was about a situation in Lebanon and
Beirut Lebanon the creator of it
her name is Katya and she she lived in
and you know grew up in in Lebanon
middle-class family or upper-middle
class I don't know
they own some apartments and she did her
college work in London because there
weren't any universities that she felt
that they she could go to in in Lebanon
that would support the fact that she
wanted to do Communication and
television and stuff like that so Louis
she her family sent her up there she
actually did quite well
she started working for the BBC and she
was there al Jazeera contact because she
could just be you know several different
languages and she even got some awards
for her work but her parents were
getting older and so she made the
decision to move back to Beirut and you
know stay with her her family for a
while and maybe see if maybe things how
things were there and she realized when
she met with some of her friends that
she had grown up with that a lot of
things had gotten worse and in Lebanon
they you know of course had had you know
there were some bombings and and there
were areas where where neighborhoods
where it used to be safe and they're no
longer safe and she realized there was
something that she wanted to say and she
felt that women especially were the ones
who who are not progressing and in
Lebanon her FAFSA teen is about three
women who eventually become best friends
and one is her husband has left her with
their kid at his parents place he's
through with marriage he doesn't want
that he doesn't want to be married he
doesn't want to be a father and she is
left by herself
with her with their young child and with
the in-laws and she doesn't know what
she should do she just if she does not
get along with the in-laws they blame
her for everything wah
yep my our has our son wouldn't have
left if you were a good wife or you were
a good mother and constantly blaming her
so she needs to find a place to stay she
ends up staying finding a place to stay
in an apartment building and the
gal who was the daughter of the
apartment owner it's very creative and
and she likes to make movies and she
likes to you know she's just curious
about things and she writes and she does
poetry and she's just very creative and
and her father keeps saying when are you
just gonna settle down and get married I
should just marry you off and of course
she doesn't want that and so the father
those I mean they're the parents are
well-meaning but they're very
old-fashioned about it but she she talks
sweet talks her father and accepting
this woman to be in one of their
apartments the woman has to work and so
she takes the the son she needs a tutor
for oh no what is it
no she she's a tutor and so she tutors
for this woman who is very wealthy and
seat but she has a couple of kids but
her husband works in Dubai and so she's
by herself but she's got a nanny she's
got all this but she needs a tutor so
the woman who's whose divorce is the
tutor but it's these three women who
actually become very good friends and
what she did at the end of each web
series was they got to vote on the
ending the audience the audience has got
to vote for the ending and then they
would show the ending at the beginning
of the next episode on them whichever
one got the vote and I asked her well
why did you do that and she said I
wanted to give women the opportunity to
vote to have an option because they have
so few options in my country and FAFSA
teen won the grand prize at the
Marseilles web fest
Wow and I'm sorry what was the name of
her arrested Jean Vasa - yes okee en
great yeah and it's a it's an amazing
one yeah there's another one that's
great a gal named teal Sherer always
wanted to be an actress ever since she
was a little girl unfortunately at the
age of 14 she was in a horrible car
accident and she was paralyzed
and from the waist down and so she was
in a wheelchair but she didn't stop her
she just was determined she also was a
dancer when she went to college she
helped to put together a dance group
that was comprised of people with
disabilities and non-disability z' and
and she got a degree in communication
and theatrical in theatre arts she moved
to Los Angeles and was trying to get
parts but of course there's no don't
seem to very many parts were but she met
this one gal Felicia day who created the
first noon websit one of the first web
series called the guild and Felicia
created a character for her because she
thought it was perfect because all of
her casts is our people that are their
characters are ones that sit in front of
the games and they just do games all day
they're gamers and they all quirky
people and so perfect the scales are
like wheelchairs so they only steer from
here up anyway so she did that and teal
thought about it and she says you know I
I think I should do with a webseries
about all the trials and tribulations of
what it's like for me being a struggling
actress in a wheelchair and so it she
created it as a comedy which is what I
loved about it is that it was taking a
social issue and it was giving it a
comedic twist to it so people were being
advised of what was going on they were
being advised of how tough difficult it
is for people with disabilities what are
some of the misconceptions or
stereotypes that people have about
people with disabilities things like
even as simple as people talking louder
to them because they think they can't
yeah well I can't walk it's not like I
can't yeah the people feeling they
needed to talk differently to people
just because they have a disability but
teal is just an amazing gal her hers is
called my gimpy life okay and and I just
absolutely loved it and I I talked about
her at least like
kay web fest in Seoul Korea hello and it
was interesting because afterwards a gal
came up and she said I'm so glad you
would you told us about about this woman
who's disabled because my sister younger
sister has a leg deformity and she can't
walk the way everybody else is she can't
even run she can't you know play sports
or anything and she just stays in a room
and she keeps to herself and she just
watches things on the computer and she
doesn't socialize but she says you know
I've got to show this to her
so she could see what can be done and
because she is so involved with the
computer and looking at me she watches
she streams stuff all the time because
she doesn't she doesn't even watch
television with her friends she just
watches things on the computer because
she's very so you know she's not
anti-social but she's I think she's just
feels less conspicuous she feels more
comfortable being by herself so anyway
it was really interesting I just it
warmed my heart to know that just by one
person knowing about they could help
this this her sister so I went and told
teal about it I called her and I said
teal you're not gonna believe this and I
told her what the story and she said oh
my god and she said it made her cheer up
just to know that her web series got
through to somebody else and that it's
it's making a change and it's this is in
Korea that this woman is yeah and I said
you now have a fan base in Korea so web
series are especially the ones that have
social issues and a lot more women now
are able I noticed a lot more women who
are creators producers directors and
acting in webseries than the percentage
in film and television which is pretty
amazing too so women are very much in
charge in web series is a really good
opportunity to break in in that way and
just as an example of some people who
have broken in there's a gal named Issa
Rae
yeah and she came to our first one I
first in our second one with
misadventures of awkward black girl
which has now been
into insecure and with hbl and has just
like it's been and they're there already
you know doing the next season's
episodes some amazing and more
importantly she got nominated for a
Golden Globe in her first year Wow
another example there's a new
you-know-who Randall Park is for the
name uh-huh okay Randall Park starred in
two web series and he even got some
awards at the LA web fest and then he
got hired on fresh off the boat oh wow
he plays the father and fresh mouth okay
and so he's stunning incredibly well
Gina Rodriguez who was with Jane the
version she starred in a couple of web
series and she got nominated and won a
Golden Globe in her first year as jane
the virgin so all of these people got
their start and Issa especially she
created the role learned how to direct
it she had to eat because you sometimes
you take on multiple jobs more than in
webseries because you don't have enough
money to have individuals hired for that
but she wrote directed and starred in it
what are the key steps in developing a
webseries I know you said before it's
not really a film script so you can't
really divide it up and just say oh
great well these two pages are gonna be
the first episode you know you've got to
design it especially it sounds like for
that five minute time period I think the
most the most important thing is you
have to have a character that you that
you feel will hold the audience's
interest and he or she has to be
involved in something that is relatable
so using something that's of personal
interest to the creator is it's probably
one good way to start start with an area
of expertise that you're good at there's
a guy named Ed and I forgotten his last
name but he had a web series and his was
about a guy
who was a chef and the guy just he he he
could create great food with the women
he just couldn't do it
and he what he did was he started off
with that premise you know what is that
what does a guy got to do you know and
the fact that he eventually became you
know became a chef you know shows his
trial and error of him eventually
becoming a chef and eventually making
contacts and it's very funny because one
of his favorite things as he goes to the
same sushi shop a couple of times a week
and the real reason he goes it's not
just because he likes the sushi because
he has a crush on this one gal who works
there and unfortunately he sees this
asian guy come in and giving giving you
know give me the gal hug and everything
and then and all this and saying I
missed you and all this so he thinks oh
my god she's got a husband or a
boyfriend so you know and she's
interested in him too you know and she
flirts with him and and always asking
him oh how are you doing and all this
it's really cute and it turns out by the
end of the first season at the I think
the last episode he finds he finds out
that that's her brother and and then the
the the love interest starts as the love
interest and everything grows from that
but it's starting off with something
that you and may be in an area that you
know about like in his case it was in
fact his I think his uh his web series
cuz it's called pairings oh okay
you know mm-hmm and so you usually think
of pairings is like okay what wine goes
with this kind of dinner or whatever but
it talks about you know it's it's a play
on words about you know what it was like
for this poor guy who's a good cook but
just can't see he can cook everything in
anything but he just can't seem to get a
gal yeah but he did he take this from
his own experience he was a chef or he
is a chef yeah okay and in fact he uses
that as a way
to advertise what he does is he will say
if you subscribe to our you know to our
web series and it doesn't cost anything
to subscribe and in his case it didn't
he says
I'll you know you'll get this week's
recipes oh yeah so something a little
different but just something that's you
know which kind of makes it interesting
for the viewer and the fans and as it
turns out this guy now is going to be I
think at last I heard someone told me
that he was planning on doing a cookbook
and that there's also an olive oil
company I believe and a winery that
advertised now so he got sort of it so I
mean he didn't purposely go out to do
that so we were talking a little bit
about you know well I have to find a
sponsor first in this case the sponsor
found right so so build it and then wait
you know sort of that then Field of
Dreams yeah and there's a don't but
don't set out to have a beer only if you
don't have the story
mmm-hmm you know you you know I in his
case he just was fascinated by by
webseries and he always you know enjoyed
writing and telling stories so for him
to do that and to you know his day job
was what was being a chef right and so
it he combined the two of them and so I
think that's you know there are no okay
first you do this this isn't that you
know there's it's hard to it's the same
thing as any kind of writing you got to
sit down put your button the chair her
and do it that's that's the first step
and he you know most of the successful
web series I've seen a lot of them
started off by taking a character not
unlike sometimes themselves and trying
to see okay what area of what is it
surrounding what's the environment like
another friend of mine that did a web
series did one she's lesbian and she
notice that there weren't any lesbian
webseries and she wanted to talk about
the fact that a lot of people don't
understand that really you know no
matter what your sexuality is people
have stories and they have the same
fears and insecurities that all of us go
through when we're in a relationship
and so she did did one and it's it's in
Australia and it's called starting from
now and it's becoming an internet
sensation they have fans all over the
world and they want a lot of awards but
she took the world that she was in and
she thought how can how can I do
something that's going to be interesting
and yet you know and and have characters
that I think people are gonna care about
and when you look at it those characters
they worry about their job just like we
do they worry about what their families
are gonna think just like we do they
worry about what the political
situations are like or what they're
worried about people cheating on them
and you see all of those things play out
they are now finishing up I think they
may have finished up by now their fifth
season
oh so they've done incredibly well
what's the name of that one it comes
starting from now starting from now okay
and it's just it's based in Australia
but you can see it here I mean you can
just google it you'll it'll come up I
just want to switch gears for a second
and we'll talk about authors just really
quickly so what should authorize in
industry approach versus writing a book
versus writing a screenplay well first
of all you can't sell anything till you
have a product and so having a book is
is the the first thing getting it
published and what's the the with
self-publishing I know a lot of people
now saying well it's self-publishing and
I've published a book that sometimes you
know that some some places will accept
that some places won't what I find
interesting though is that in most of
the major publishing houses there is a
rights division and what you need to do
is find if your novel
and you think your your novel is
something that could be adapted into a
movie or a TV series or whatever go to
the whoever heads up the rights
department and find out how they feel
about it and can they send something out
why sends your book out to maybe
producers or a particular actress or or
whatever publishing houses usually can
do that whether they will or not I think
it depends on how overworked they are
but that's that's really how a lot of
books end up in Hollywood is because
somebody in the rights department at the
publishing house sometimes even when
they buy the rights and it hasn't even
been published yet it's just they've
signed the contract but they've already
read the story and thought god I could
see this is a movie that sometimes it
automatically will just go to one of the
studios I know you talked about in your
book on writing and it was a chapter 12
group therapy for writers what you say
is getting the most out of writing
conferences and writers groups just as
there's different you know some actors
are great in certain classes and
sometimes it's not a fit how does
someone know if it's a fit in terms of
the writing group how do we know that
you know what this is the writing group
for me or maybe nice people but I need
to move on I don't know if this is
really the fit for me I think it depends
on where you're at certainly if you've
written a couple of books a couple of
short short stories or something and
you've you know if you have some
material behind you already whether or
not it's published or not but you've
you've written a body of work you have
things to show I think it's it's you may
not want to be in a ranked beginning one
a ranked beginning group you may want to
find a group that's already you know
where everybody has at least they're
almost finished with their first one or
they actually have had something
published or they have a couple of short
stories that they've done or something
in other words it's not just starting
off at the very beginning I haven't
written anything yet and this is a
beginning writers group you want to try
and find one that's at the same level
that you are
at the same time for people who just
finished writing their first thing or
just about ready to you know try and get
their work out there finding a writers
group that's in their same genre is also
very helpful mystery writers have a lot
of groups
children's books they have a lot of
groups in fact and I'm gonna be doing a
workshop for our children's book writers
and a couple of days they're you know
finding it in the genre that you're in
is important because not it's not just
general book writing yeah we're just
going to do this and you know because if
it's if you're writing in mysteries or
romance novels
you know historical dramas those kind of
books if you're in a particular genre of
a book it's best to be in a group that
also has the same type of focus it
because certain agents look for certain
only certain kinds of genres in writing
so you know this is what's helpful is
that you know again they have regular
writing conferences to South Carolina
Writers Pacific Northwest writers
California writers has went to the
Greater Los Angeles area writers group
there's one looks like says gloss gla to
us there's a lot of them all over the
place and and usually every state has at
least one or two writing conferences
where agents come and you can book five
ten-minute appointments for them to take
a look at your work order or us where
some of them will read like the first
the synopsis and tell you whether or not
they feel that your book is a good fit
for them or not and sometimes you know
they've people been very successful in
that so writing conferences for
novelists are also quite good if you do
that and writing groups like the South
Carolina Writers I mean they're they
have writers in all different arenas
and they break off into smaller groups
according to you know genres and now
where does someone find these local
writing groups I was this like meetup
yeah meetup is a great one yeah meetup
is a really really good one in fact
there's a gal I know who who writes and
what she does is when she knows she's
gonna be you know going on vacation or
something
she has an agreement with her husband
that he takes care of the kids for one
day and she goes and finds a meet-up at
wherever they're going for a writers
group and she just she's so funny she
she's I told her what she should do is
she should write a short story about it
because she has met so many interesting
people at these meet up once and it's
great because then she has hosted some
of these people from the different mud
when they come to her city they do that
she meets up with them and she so she's
made a lot of friends that way too I
noticed with some of these meetups not
just even writing groups but there's a
there's a cost to join it's you know and
and I get why because someone's hosting
it maybe they have material that they're
providing and also I think they want to
know are these people going to be
serious and not just show up so what do
you think is a reasonable cost to join
for a writers group whether it's per
week or per month gosh you know I really
don't know because I the ones that I've
seen it's usually maybe per event mm-hmm
and it depends like the children's
writers group that that that I am going
to be speaking at it's $45 but it
includes my book okay
and so my book is $20 so it's it's you
know they and the rest of the money
helps to pay for the venue
sure and refreshments and and and that
so you know I think you just have to
gauge it a lot of them though I've
noticed they're free to a non Meetup
okay on meetup I've seen some that are
just per bar are free they don't but
it's just a meeting it's just just a
bunch of writers getting together and
just talking about all the different
things that you know about anything to
do with writing
and maybe they discuss you know a little
bit about their you know about their
material and and all that so it's it's
it depends I mean some of them there are
no costs I've seen somewhere where it
doesn't say anything about a cost but
I've also seen some that were as high as
50 $60 and usually though it's because
there's a speaker and you have to pay
the speaker or you or in this case for
the children book writers you actually
get a copy of the book so you're getting
something in return as well you're
getting a book as well as being able to
hear it hear a workshop what about the
public library do they offer writing
groups I mean do they organize that or
no you know I think they used to but I
just you know I hate to say it but at
least here in California I've noticed
what's very sad is that libraries are at
risk yeah and not just down here in
Southern California in central
California where I live it's it's like
that too they just can't sponsor those
kinds of things library hours are being
cut shorter notice to do you I mean I
remember when I could go to the library
at 8 o'clock at night and make my Xerox
copies if I needed something done or
something and I noticed now it now
closes at 5:30 they used to be open all
day Saturday and Sunday I noticed
they're not open on Sunday same with art
but certain other towns are but not City
of LA where we are yeah and I think it
just depends on the area that you're in
you know where I do think they've got a
great system is San Francisco San
Francisco Public Library System is
beyond par it's just as amazing and they
have speakers that come constantly and
it's free that's wonderful yeah so it's
a you know meetup groups are great if
you live in San Francisco go to check
out the public libraries they do they
and there's a lot of writers who live in
and around that Bay Area that actually
come and speak for free whenever one of
their new books comes out you know I
know you've been a big proponent
of writers asking questions questions
concerning anything about their career
or whatever but why would a writer be
afraid to ask questions
I think people in general sometimes are
afraid to ask questions for whatever
reason a lot of times and I and I used
to be this way too when I was a kid I
used to think well if I asked a question
people are going to think I'm stupid or
that I you know why would I ask the
court I must not know what I'm doing and
it's the same I think the older we get
well a lot of times you know how many of
you out there you know have been afraid
to ask their boss you know a question
because you don't know what they're
gonna say are they gonna think you're
stupid or you don't know what you're
doing I think sometimes asking questions
if you know and you especially if you're
asking them and you phrase it in a way
that that is asking for advice I think
then people love it but people like
being asked for advice so I always
believe there's something I call the
open-ended question the open-ended
question is is saying something in a way
where you are not asking for a question
that has a yes-or-no answer you want to
get information and this is especially
helpful when you maybe have won an
interview with somebody you know like if
you're pitching and you maybe have
finished your pitch and they have
finished giving you feedback and if they
say oh do you have any other questions
that's the perfect time for an
open-ended question such as what are
some of the genres that you guys are
interested in doing in the future you
know that's not a yes or no answer and
it's getting valuable information so
that you know oh okay you know if they
say oh well you're we're looking for an
action piece or something like that or
I'm looking for a romance novel or
something you know if you have something
like that that's a perfect way for you
to then say oh you know I've got a I've
got a romantic comedy and and you can do
a logline on it and you know it's it's
halfway done and you know would you be
interested in taking a look at it one I
mean it's a way of breaking the ice too
and opening up your conversation
so an open-ended question is just the
most amazing thing it's not asking
something that's oh well do you like
this or not that's yes or no no you're
asking for their advice other quite
other kinds of examples of open-ended
questions what do you think about that
or not you know you mentioned such and
such as as being a problem can you can
you give me some examples of this
so you haven't better idea you're
extending the one you're extending the
conversation to your gathering more
information and three you're
establishing a relationship a back and
forth relationship they're going to
remember they are more likely to
remember that conversation with you
should you contact them later
you know and especially if you do a
little thank-you note that says you know
that says dear so-and-so thank you so
much for taking the time to answer my
questions I really enjoyed talking with
you and about you know such and such as
mentioned I have a I finally finished my
romantic my romance novel or my romance
comedy or whatever and here's a you know
I'm attaching a little short paragraph
about it and if you think this is of
interest
I mean you've started now a relationship
how successful that relationship is I'm
not sure but at least you that's the way
you start a relationship and that's how
you you know if by answering and asking
open-ended questions within your own
writers group as well that's where I say
start to practice there first then you
can start using it on things like when
you go to pitch fest or when you go to
meet with them maybe you know somebody
who's who's a producer or an agent or
something
so that's you know to me that's that's
the best way to start getting your your
work out there and getting yourself used
to it is asking questions yeah and I
think it indicates interests too and
definitely you know because if someone
says well degree do you have any
questions for me no
think so then you think oh they're not
they're done they want to leave but if
you show yes I do it shows that this is
something you want to commit time to
you're interested you're willing you're
open
yeah but the open-ended question it's
something I learned very early because I
was a journalism major and when you
interview people you don't want to just
get a yes or no answer so I it's
something that has worked really really
well for me and it's worked really well
for my clients too because they it's
such a simple thing but you need to kind
of practice it a little bit and it does
it shows interest it also when you ask
people for their advice people even a
boss likes to be asked for his advice
and I don't I think it's just the way
that you that you ask it and it's
surprising how the results that you
might get when a screenwriter finishes
the screenplay is there a checklist that
they should sort of mentally or
physically check off in terms of the
business aspects of getting the script
out there not just proofreading and
grammar and syntax all that but I'm
talking about in terms of you know what
are the next steps who should they be
sending things out should they make a
chart of who they sent it out to I think
it's a good idea to see you need to have
a checklist or a chart certainly sending
it out to a consultant or somebody who
professional in the in the industry is
is always very helpful because it gives
you an idea of from somebody who has
been in the industry a long time what is
it that might what are the little things
and some of the bigger things that might
keep it from moving ahead I think that
also if you if you have a I think one of
the things that bothers me is when I is
when I see that people really haven't
taken the time to proof I'm not kidding
you that's a major thing I have when I
was an executive I actually had cohorts
in my office who were also execs who if
they found more than three mistakes in
the
first 20 pages they would not they would
stop reading and they've throw it in the
trash he just hate to say that but that
happens that really honest-to-god that
that does happen on the other hand I'm
always looking give me a reason to say
yes you know so make sure that you're
you know you know the structure of your
your screenplay is such that right off
the bat it catches your attention that
that we are that you've got characters
that are so relatable that we're gonna
want to see them and see them either
succeed or or to see the guy the
antagonists fail that's one of the one
of the big things that I say is a lot of
times people will pay more attention to
the hero and the unfortunate thing is
they don't set up the antagonists well
enough that it gives the hero enough
enough enough contrast and interest
that's a big thing that I see a lot and
sometimes in the things that I've read
is that they just the whoever he's up
against whether whether it doesn't have
to be a person it could be the elements
you know it's like a storm or something
or or it could just you know it could
just be himself but you don't see enough
contrast in what's going on and so I
think that's another big mistake that
that people make in that they they
should take a look at it and have
somebody read it and just say you know
and ask that question is my antagonist
strong enough yeah do you understand
what's at stake and do you feel that the
hero has has worked hard enough to
achieve that success what's the
difference though between getting
coverage and getting consultation
okay coverage a lot of people say okay
yeah I'm gonna get coverage on this so
they will send it out coverage is
something that we use in the studio just
to see just so that the executive will
know what is the story about because
they sometimes don't have time to read
the whole script it takes about an hour
and a half to read a script and with a
thousand scripts coming in every month
it's a lot of reading so that's why they
have story departments
who do the reading so coverage is just
like a book report it has a it tells you
it has a little log line in the front
which is one or two sentences that tells
you the the general idea of what the
story's about and then it's basically
just telling you the story just like a
regular book report
this is what happens and it usually is
done in chronological order and then it
usually tells you a little bit you know
there'll be box scores or something that
will tell you okay is this a big budget
you know where does it fall in the
budget is that how do you how would you
grade it in terms of do you think the
dialogue was was well-written do you
think the care you understood the
characters and that they're they they
have a story worth telling you know they
don't have those kind of little boxes
and you mark them off that usually says
you know like excellent good bad fare
you know that like that and poor and
they just check those off and then they
just write a little thing about I feel
that this is that I I feel that the
character that the hero is too weak and
there's just not enough interest in here
you know for us there's not enough at
stake for us to really root for him you
know so they might give a few things
what a consultation does is they not
only read your whole script they go
through and they usually tell you
exactly what they feel does not work
they get into details your dialogue is
two on the news or we you you mentioned
this character in the beginning but we
don't know why do you include this
character if there's no payoff at the
end for the character or they'll say
gosh you know I I like your hero but you
know you're for some reason I don't
quite understand why your dialogue
doesn't match the personality that
you've given him that happens a lot to
where you know people people put their
own words into the character rather than
the characters words into the dialogue
and that happens a lot too
so that those are just some of the
things that you know that consultants
will find
I think the good thing too about having
a consultant is they will tell you you
know if you like for right now if you
send in something that has to do with
zombies or it has to do with you know
dystopian ideas and some sometimes
they'll you know a consultant will say
you know look they they don't mind but
it has to have this and this and this
zombies are we've had too much too many
submissions on that they probably aren't
if their chances kind of go down if it's
about zombies I mean they will give you
hopefully some up-to-date information on
what they were they've gleaned from
reading the trade papers and and all
that so I that's what I do when I do a
consultation I will be very upfront
about what I feel works and doesn't work
about they're not just about the writing
but about the script in general and how
the marketplace is now because I don't
want to ever lead them in the wrong
direction
and I will be very upfront I'm not gonna
be like brutal in my I'm not I try not
to be brutal because nobody deserves
that but if somebody we recently had
somebody last year send me a script
about zombies and I had to be very
honest about it and I said you know this
would have been a good script for people
to consider three years ago
unfortunately I know for a fact that I
was recently at such-and-such you know
at the script fest and and I know that
several agents have said they do do not
want to see any more zombie scripts be
they feel that that that they've just
been too many of them I mean you have to
be honest about it I don't want to build
up their hopes on that I've done things
also where I have said do you think you
can make a transition here where instead
of zombies maybe it has to do with
something that like that there's there
are people here who are actually aliens
who have come to earth or you know I
help them come to a way that they can
maybe change it so that the heart of the
story remains but the situation itself
like zombies or something can be changed
I mean it's it's different ways of being
in different consultations differ a lot
I try to do that if I can with with mine
and I think a lot of my my colleagues do
that too where we try to find out what
we feel is the best of what they are
doing and letting them know what that is
and that this is this is what we liked
about it and then let them know this is
what could be a problem and also along
with it what whatever new information we
can give them such as you know this is
we think that zombies have had their run
we've been talking to you know we were
on panels and we've talked to agents and
producers and and this is what seems you
know this is not this is the and I
sometimes ye even put these are some of
the areas that they're looking at if
they happen to mention anything you know
like they're looking for you know more
action pieces or whatever the whatever
you know they are looking for I I just
try to give them a little bit more
additional information about where they
could take this project or where they
could themselves what they want to start
another project what area they might
want to start in